hi my name is Ryan Johnson and I'm a
data science advisor here at posit and
I'm excited to host our first ever posit
team Community demo on April 26th and
we'll continue this series of demos on
the last Wednesday of every month going
forward
now during these demos we'll walk
through an end-to-end data science
workflow using our three professional
data science tools that make up positive
team a posit workbench posit connect and
posit package manager
now most importantly these events are
open to the entire data science
Community now you may ask yourself like
why would I want to attend these posit
team demos so here are a few reasons why
I believe these sessions will be
valuable not just to posit customers but
also the greater data science community
so first off maybe you've never heard of
positing before either you're new to a
company that uses positive team or
you're just exploring options for your
team's analytics platforms so during
these demos we'll make sure to provide a
high level overview of pause a team and
also highlight some of the newest
features we've added to our dual chain
now secondly maybe you do use positive
team today and you're looking to expand
your data science capabilities for
example is your team thinking about
using python more maybe creating some
Dash applications or hosting your first
API every month we'll keep things fresh
and discuss a new topic and touch upon
the various capabilities within positive
and finally this is a great time to ask
us at posit any questions you have about
positive during this demo we'll be
hanging out in the chat to answer any
and all of your questions you have about
positive workflows capabilities
licensing and more we hope these demos
are valuable to you and the data science
team and we look forward to seeing you
there